when i'm going through change in my life
or i
have a specific outcome that i want to
create i love
to get up early in the morning that's my
time i'm a 4 30 in the morning guy
because
that's my time the rest of the day i'm
serving but
i love getting up early and changing and
working and and having some time to
myself and i believe that when i invest
in myself
i invest in my future and that time in
my
in my morning nobody bothers me because
that's my time
and because of brain waves and brain
chemistry
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind
is more open and so if i get up early
and i'm kind of between
theta and alpha i don't have to work as
hard i'm not thinking
i just kind of relax into the moment in
the evening i always ask myself how did
i do
how was one lifetime in one day where
did i fall from grace what happened
and so then when i look at seeing how i
reacted to someone or something or i
made the
choice that i could have made a better
choice i naturally
and we all do this begin to think well
if the same situation happened again how
would i do it differently
and that's the act of beginning to come
up with a new plan
the act of rehearsing it in your mind
begins to install the circuits in your
brain priming your brain
so that when the next experience happens
you could modify your behavior to do a
better job
in life that's called plasticity so
it doesn't matter for me what meditation
i do any longer
i like to just get up in a new state of
being i have people say to me hey
i miss my meditation today like i'm
supposed to go like this or something
and i say to them eyes open our eyes
closed
you know my eyes open our eyes closed
you know when you're passionate about
something
you know when people can't get up in the
morning and they can't get out of bed
i'm going to tell you why because they
can predict the feeling of everything
that's going to happen in their life
and their bodies resigned to the
familiar it says another mundane day
but remember when you were a kid and you
were going on a field trip
what happened then you were up and
dressed and ready to go before your
parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding to
expect the unexpected
and something unusual should happen in
our life as a result of our efforts
and it's just those beginning moments
where it begins to happen
that we begin to prove to ourselves how
powerful we really are
so take time in the morning in the
evening and the rest of the day
check in with yourself at certain times
to see if you're still in that energy
and if you're not excuse yourself for a
second raise your energy and step back
into your life
if you keep doing that over and over
again you'll become less frustrated less
impatient
less judgmental it'll just become
something of the past and you'll be
someone else
70 of the time people live in stress and
living in stress is living in survival
now
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress you know
a deer gets chased by a pack of coyotes
when it outruns the coyotes
it goes back to grazing and the event is
over and the definition of stress is
when your brain and body are knocked out
of balance out of homeostasis
the stress response is what the body
innately does to return itself back to
order
so you're driving down the road someone
cuts you off you jam on the brakes you
may
give them the finger and then you settle
back down and the event is over and boom
now everything's back back to normal but
what if it's not a predator that's
waiting for you
uh outside the cave but what if it's
your co-worker
sitting right next to you and all day
long you're turning on those chemicals
because they're pushing all your
emotional buttons
when you turn on the stress response and
you can't turn it off
now you're headed for disease because no
organism in nature can live in emergency
mode for that
extended period of time it's a
scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes and create disease
long-term effects human beings because
of the size of the neocortex we can turn
on the stress response just by thought
alone we can think about our problems
and turn on those chemicals
that means then our thoughts
could make us sick so if it's possible
that our thoughts could make us sick is
it possible then our thoughts can make
us well
the answer is absolutely yes so then
what are the emotions that are connected
to survival let's name them
anger aggression hostility hatred
competition fear anxiety worry
pain suffering guilt shame unworthiness
envy jealousy those are all created by
the hormones of stress and
and psychology calls them normal human
states of consciousness
i call those altered states of
consciousness
so then we tend to remember those
traumatic events more because
in survival you better be ready if it
happens again that's
and and when survival gene is switched
on you could have 10 really great things
that happened to you in your day
and you just have one bad thing that
happens and you cannot
take your attention off that bad that
that unhappy thing because
the survival gene is switched on many
years ago after
the dna helix was discovered by watson
crick
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are
created from genes it turns out less
than five percent more like one percent
of people on the planet are born with a
genetic condition like type 1 diabetes
or
tay sachs disease or sickle cell anemia
the other 95 to 99 percent
are created by lifestyle and by choices
you can take two identical twins
exact same genome one dies at 51. the
other one dies at 85.
same gene different environment so
all of a sudden they said we lied that
was wrong it's not
genes that create disease it's the
environment that signals the gene
that creates disease well okay but
that's not the whole truth too because
you could have two people working side
by side in the same factory
one gets cancer after being exposed to a
carcinogenic for 25 years
both working for 25 years the other one
has no cancer at all
so there must be some internal order
that would cause one person to not get
it while another one does
so is it possible then if the
environment
signals the gene and it does and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is called an emotion
can you signal the gene ahead of the
environment by embracing an elevated
emotion
we've done the research on this we
measured 7500 different gene expressions
in a group of people that came to an
advanced event for four days
and we had them doing a seated
meditation a walking meditation a laying
down meditation a standing meditation
and at the end of four days just four
days
the common eight genes that were up
regulated two genes to suppress
cancer cells and tumor growth two genes
for neurogenesis the growth of new
neurons in response to novel experiences
and learning
the gene that signals stem cells to go
to damaged areas and repair them
the gene for oxidative stress was
upregulated
we started seeing all these genes that
are very very healthy to cause the body
to flourish imagine
if people were doing that for three
months we also measured telomeres
the little shoestrings on the end of dna
that tell us our biological age we asked
people
to do the work meditation five out of
seven days for 60 days
measure their telomeres that determine
their biological age 60 days later
74 of the people lengthen their
telomeres
40 significant change 20 a very
remarkable change
that means that they got a little bit of
their life back if it lengthened by 10
they got 10 percent of their life back i
think uh
you know if we everything starts with a
thought i mean everything that you do in
your life
you you have to have a thought before
you initiate an action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like
any great leader in history understands
that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so
give you an example most people wake up
in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those
problems are connected to certain people
and things at certain times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits
those memories are actually causing them
to think
in the past every single one of those
memories has an emotion associated with
them and emotions are the end product of
past experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the
they recall some problem in their life
they start feeling unhappy they start
feeling discouraged they start feeling
anxious
now thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how you think and how you
feel creates your state of being so we
could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past
well if you live in the familiar past
then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future
so what happens for most people is they
get stuck in their biology so think
about this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion
and an emotion that you can create by
thought alone so if you're living by the
same emotion every single day and those
emotions are influencing your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking
you're thinking in the past your lens of
the future
is going to be colored by the past so
you can't see possibilities so
most people like to wait for crisis or
disease or diagnosis before they wake up
enough to see well the challenge is is
that biology tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts begin to fire certain
circuits in your brain
the nerve cells that fire together wire
together so all of a sudden you start
getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time
those thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so
some people would rather cling to the
familiar than take a chance in
possibilities so
for most people then they say well i
don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so
the first step to change is starting to
think about what you've been thinking
about
and change it and and then when you
begin to observe those thoughts you're
no longer the program you're the
consciousness observing just simply by
being an observer of your thoughts right
so
so though so most people though when
they when you do that when you decide to
really take a look it's like lighting a
match in a dark place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well
when you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain
because your attention on those thoughts
begins to
reorganize circuitry re-mold the brain i
think this is a time in history where
it's not enough to know
this is a time in history to know how
and if you rewind the tape 10 years ago
you know information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and
and as we learn new things we make new
connections in our brains so
as we begin to add new stitches into
that three-dimensional tapestry in our
mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then
is to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it in in 10 years ago
when i went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because
doing something means you're gonna have
to change something about yourself
yeah you're gonna get uncomfortable
right and um
i think we're in an age of information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice
and because of technology we have access
to so much content
and information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and
you can't have consciousness without
energy there they work together so
there's an energetic change i think
that's taking place in the world right
now where people are so informed
that old models old paradigms are
beginning to break down whether it's the
medical model or the religious model the
educational model journalism
the economy you know politics it's all
beginning to come to the surface because
something else
has to come out and and i think that one
of the things that
people are realizing is that you don't
have to be a buddhist monk to do this or
a nun with 40 years of devotion you just
got to understand the formula
and just like any skill or anything you
learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge
you create the experience and if you
keep doing it over and over again you
start getting a skill or you start
getting wise about how to do it
and you you know that you know how to do
it i think we've been
hypnotized and conditioned into becoming
materialists
i think that we define reality with our
senses and i think that is one of the
biggest delusions so
the fundamental question is can you
believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought
about enough times in your mind that
your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already occurred now the latest research
in plasticity says that's absolutely
possible
and can you select a new possibility in
the quantum field
and begin to emotionally embrace that
future every single day
to such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind
the objective mind does not know the
difference between the experience
in your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree
that you begin to signal new genes and
new ways
to change your body to look like the
experience has already happened now yes
the latest research in epigenetics says
it's absolutely possible now think about
this
every day installing the circuitry
every day conditioning the body into the
emotion of the future
that your body begins to change to look
like it's already happened now this
is where it gets fun because now
you no longer have to go anywhere to get
it
now it begins to come to you you become
the vortex or the magnet to your destiny
so then people who come out of their
meditation and they say well i
just focused on my wealth why isn't it
there well you're not that good
if you're asking why isn't it there
you're back to the old person again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time
as an experiment as the scientist
in your life to keep your energy
connected to the
to the dream of your future and then
see what kind of effects begin to take
place
without moving into impatience
without moving into frustration without
starting to analyze
why it hasn't happened or when that is
the trap
of defining reality with your senses so
you have the thought of your future and
you don't see it then you experience
separation
but people who are practicing this work
they have the thought of their future
and they feel the emotion of their
future
they're still connected to it right so
that takes practice
and it's just learning like hitting a
golf ball hitting a tennis ball
dancing the salsa you know crocheting
whatever it is you gotta
you gotta start out staying real
conscious and learning then you get good
at it and it gets to be instrumental it
gets to be fun and that's
that's what i want for everybody that
the the act of creation
should be a blissful ecstatic loose
uh free process and um and so
i love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
to prove to themselves that if they're
defined by the vision of the future
then they're not living by the memories
of the past and that's where the unknown
exists so
many people the unknown is a scary place
so they don't see that future
because they're used to seeing that
future with evidence with their senses
and you have to be able to get beyond
that and stay in the unknown
stay in that discomfort and then in that
moment
to be begin to self-regulate like oh i'm
starting to feel a little anxiety ooh
i'm starting to feel a little
frustration
that's the defining moment where your
body's going back to the past because
emotions are a record of the past
or you go into routine again so you
catch yourself
it's a victory and if you keep catching
yourself
those victories add up and it's not so
much
about your wealth or your health or your
freedom or your new relationship
it's actually about who you become if
you want to know the seven rich people
habits that you need to try today
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there it was very
difficult for me to figure out
where my boundaries were because
i'd grown up poor and didn't have
anything